am I doing
[Laughter]
a lot of singing a lot of dancing a lot
of naked
right hey EET this is James Marsden and
this is my ET retrospective hi
hello
The Nanny my very first job ever
actually I was well boy 19 years old
early on I was in some of those like
teeny bot magazines and Jimmy sounded
kind of I guess younger and I was you
know starting to feel a little more
arrogant as an adult I'm like I need to
be taken seriously as an actor so I'm
going to James when I was younger James
is is also my father's name and it just
sounded very fatherly so but uh yeah
Jimmy got shed I don't I don't know
early 2000s maybe maybe after X-Men
cyclops right Flash Forward the X-Men
this was the project that sort of
catapulted me into you know whatever
people knowing who the hell I was that
kind of put me on the map in Hollywood
and and people knew who I was and
whether you know it was it was Hugh
Jackman's show for sure and it just
obviously sent him into the stratosphere
but uh but what a great family what a
great opportunity to to take a lot of
boxes off there and uh still to this day
I think it's probably the thing I get
noticed for the most X-Men right back up
back up it was a time or two my son
dressed up as Cyclops for Halloween I
think it's a fun thing for them to do
but they also kind of ribbed me about it
too like yeah such a wimp in that movie
oh wow Ally McBeal
what am I doing there my God
boy
they didn't hire me for the dancing
that's for sure
talk with David Kelly and he said that's
really why we hired you because your
dancing skills and you do a lot of music
and dancing on the set just made that
joke
we're taking myself too seriously and
and obviously you want the work to be
good but uh anytime you're just
presented with these situations where
you're dancing without music or doing
something silly it's like that's the
life that I'm gonna have an actor I
guess the rich kids over there I guess I
guess okay here we go The Notebook the
movie that no one thought would become
what it's become in the 50s and 60s when
people would say Casablanca is the most
romantic movie like now a younger
generation would if you think of what's
the most romantic movie that comes to
mind most people would say the notebook
and uh so I feel very proud to be a part
of it even if I'm
you know the other guy
which you're gonna go on to the next
projects and we're gonna get on that
theme I can't wait wondering if I could
take you out I thought that was absurd
that scene I was like Nick was like
you're so pretty let's mess you up a bit
and they he did certainly what comes to
mind when I think of this is I was
sitting at a cafe and Off-Broadway and I
got a tap on my shoulder and Julia
Roberts said hey I just didn't mean to
interrupt but I wanted to let you know
that you're in my favorite movie of all
time which was The Notebook he sings and
dances in in the movie and I didn't know
that he could sing or a dance all right
so here we are on hairspray this is
doing a I guess the Press junket for it
look at little Zach he's just a 12 year
old
my God
it's so tiny
um yeah that was such a party hairspray
was a blast Maybe the most fun I've ever
had on a movie
um because we were all
we were all just there having a good
time I just remember
that smile was plastered on my face even
when we weren't filming it was just so
much fun I was always trying to surprise
people with my choices and do something
that you know how do I get people to see
other sides of me that they didn't
necessarily see in like the notebook or
X-Men and hairspray came along and it
was like
I got this
sure and sweet waiting to complete oh
yes Enchanted when this script came
along
rarely do I read something and just
without a doubt go I know exactly how to
play this character and it just it just
came to me and I went I you're not gonna
you're not gonna find somebody else
and usually I'm the opposite I'm not
that confident I'm not a big wardrobe
change guy
how do I just stay in one one suit and
be happy with it even if it's big
ridiculous sleeves puffy sleeves uh I'm
fine with it but it was uh it was an
event when I had to go to the restroom
that was uh that was it was a whole
event but that was great I mean I
remember speaking of the notebook going
back to the notebook I remember running
into Ryan and Rachel and Ryan goes
did I see you on top of a bus in a print
suit in Tights uh in Times Square I said
yes sir that was me we can all have your
your uh oscar-winning uh projects and
he's like are you kidding me he goes I
would do that in a heartbeat I loved
your thong by the way
hitting the highlights here okay wow 27
Dresses yeah 27 Dresses is another one
that if I'm walking down the street
everyone asks like what are you getting
recognized for the most and 27 Dresses
is definitely one of those
[Music]
it was the last day of shooting we shot
till five in the morning
and uh
yeah it was kind of like we were having
the wrap party for the last most
important scene of the movie and I think
you you kind of see that
like there's a real organic sense of fun
to this scene and we had it Katie and I
had a great time on that movie and we
got to be really close friends and it's
like this was like us just letting loose
having a great time
and to this day if I'm in a bar
it's always like a tequila shot will get
send over and then Benny and the Jets
question mark
foreign
sex drive
also known as the movie that we can't
watch or show to anyone nowadays though
so we would all be canceled hopefully my
fans won't just like take off and run
for the hills after this one there was
some sort of liberating thing of
feeling like you're doing a project that
no one was going to see
[Applause]
and
and because I thought that it was like
who's gonna see this movie I'm just
gonna go for it and I went for it it was
like Will Ferrell called me up going
you're rolling Sex Drive is hilarious do
you want to come be an Anchorman
hello Ron Jack live Anchorman 2 it was a
living hell
for there uh that was Will's favorite
moment by the way when I do that little
whimper
um but he said hey come if you're
interested we're doing a read through of
the second Anchorman I thought
pressure because I was a huge fan of the
original uh Anchorman and we did the
read through and I remember thinking boy
you better knock it out like with your
first line because it was the first line
from Jack lame is is his best biggest
line in the movie and
I remember Jonah Hill and Seth Rogen and
every other massive audience of people
that I just respected Chad Appleton
sitting there and they're filming the
read through like we're all at a table
and it's being filmed with an audience
of 40 people
and I the first line is I call out
Across The Newsroom too I'm like can I
help you guy can I help you guy
something like that and it just
like people lost it it's the absurdity
of shouting at this guy and calling him
a guy
um so then afterwards will was like you
got the roll man come play with us
Death at a Funeral none of this is
scripted it's just like Neil Le beaut
who directed this was like
have a great time you're high you know
as an actor it's like vanity is the
thing that will keep you in shape
knowing that you have a sex scene or
like a shirtless scene like that's gonna
keep you in the gym so I was like as
long as I you know look like I'm in
shape and Neil when I got to set he was
like well this is almost not funny
because like you're too in shape like
why would this guy have this bike so
it's a true Chris Pratt audition for
this role
so Chris I've known for a while and
Chris was there when we did the read
through and Chris read
I think Wilson's role in the read
through but he really wanted my role not
my role I mean the role I was you know
campaigning for
and after the read through he's like
his mother he's like
this role is so bad it was like they're
giving it to you and I was like well get
used to it because you're going to get a
whole slew of rolls that I'm not gonna
get
I'll trade you yeah yeah I'll trade you
my Death at a Funeral for Star Trek or
whatever do you remember now today
Westworld did I remember that moment
feeling like I'd lost a bet or something
hey if you lose this bet you have to do
a three-page scene with Anthony Hopkins
fully nude I'm fully nude Anthony
Hopkins is not fully nude he's fully
dressed did you understand the plot of
Westworld by the time you finish
shooting Westworld
um hang on a second no
long as I know where my character is at
the moment what he's going through
that's the most important thing and then
I'll watch the show
and try to put the pieces together like
everyone else is
come on honey you don't know what you're
doing I'm not going anywhere oh yes dead
to me I was only supposed to be on for
the first season
uh I was only supposed to play Steve and
then that was it and the show became a
big success I was like I don't want this
party to end
so is he really dead
what can we do I remember Christina who
she and I have this great Rapport we
sort of make fun of each other and she's
you know we stepped step foot on the set
for the first day of the second season
she goes
twin huh
oh yeah she is
good luck
meow
Sonic the Hedgehog early on we got into
some like
you know sticky areas with the design of
the character and we thought oh boy this
is you know already we got our work cut
out for us to
into it I remember going to the premiere
and I had Jim Carrey sitting next to me
and Ben Schwartz here to my left and
Tikka was right in front of me and about
15 minutes in the movie we all looked at
each other and we're like
it's actually really good
who knew and now James has another
surprise hit on his hands jury duty
streaming now on freebie James as
himself is on a fake jury listening to a
fake case everyone is an actor except
for juror number six Ronald who doesn't
know it's all pretend jury duty yeah it
matters to me just tell me who got it
don't say Chris Pine
I want to be able to say this stuff in
the day of the day
but I can't right because I'll either
get arrested or I'll get punched you
know like I don't really want it
oh my god let's all feel sorry for the
guy from The Notebook
he's not even the guy from
scene was the toughest to film of the
entire show and in the script it says
Marsden comes in and and just destroys
the birthday party pops every balloon
throws cake at people like it's just a
full-on tantrum brat
but I made a commitment early on like I
can't make this guy feel bad I can't
make him be the butt of a joke
and as soon as I flipped that cake I saw
out of the corner of my eye his head
kind of hanged
and I was like oh I've disappointed him
and I've upset him so that was really
difficult and so then I pulled back a
bit I didn't go nuts and just destroy
the rest of the birthday party making
fun of and lampooning the your sort of
cliche
pompous
egocentric Hollywood actor who thinks
that they're doing the Lord's work it's
like where do I sign
[Music]
foreign